segment we haven't done in a while which
doesn't belong and why a nod to the
cardinal from the long defunct don i
miss show
bernard mcguirk highly inappropriate
content
especially judge by current standards
even at the time it was highly
inappropriate to the point where i
couldn't believe some of the stuff that
he would say
but he'd do it with the the accent and
uh
which doesn't belong and why would
always cap his segment
so let's get into it which doesn't
belong and why unhappy
quarterbacks which doesn't belong and
wide desean watson
russell wilson carson wentz which
doesn't belong and why
i'd say russell wilson because those
other two
uh don't want to step foot in the
in their in the buildings of their team
ever again
uh russell wilson i think probably
understands that he's not going anywhere
he just
wants the landscape to be a little bit
different
in 2021 i'm going to go with the obvious
low-hanging fruit here peter i'm going
to go with
carson wentz and i'm going to
characterize carson wentz in a way that
i vividly recall you characterizing
certain players under certain
circumstances while we were watching
games together years ago
in the nbc viewing room carson wentz you
blow
you blow so that's why he doesn't belong
was that pre tony dungy no no
no tony was in the room tony was in the
room i think what i said
i'm sorry until i've heard that i don't
think we get bleep for that in london or
elsewhere anyway uh
speaking of uh speaking of and people
hello london
watching on sky sports they get mad when
i say sorry london and don't say sorry
manchester
sorry liverpool it's the bit that's the
joke we say sorry london as the
catch-all
when i say something that i shouldn't
say so sorry
everyone all right uh deshawn watson
um the broncos according to abc7 in
denver
will pursue deshaun watson if the texans
decide to trade him now that was
strangely worded because it implies
they're not going to pursue him
unless and until the texans throw the
door open and say we're going to trade
him
why not go ahead and start making offers
even before they say they're going to
trade him
maybe they're just doing that for
leverage but peter that would shake
things up
i would say if deshawn watson ended up
with the denver broncos
i mean you have to ask yourself
what and again look what denver has that
houston would want
is not drew locke although they might
take him
in in that event what denver has is the
ninth pick in the draft
and uh a possible high pick
next year as well now who knows if they
get to sean watson
the pick's gonna go lower but uh
i i try to look at this from a logical
standpoint mike
and i try to say what teams are really
good
fits for uh
you know ford desean watson the best fit
far
far far and away is the new york jets
because of what they have in draft
choices and the fact
they have sam darnold who might might i
don't know
might be your quarterback in the future
so
that still is the best one but there
should they're going to be a lot of
teams that are going to be like denver
well if they're going to trade i'm more
interested
who wouldn't be interested you know
unless you have a
franchise quarterback on your team
you're going to be interested in that
even teams you think might not be
interested san francisco
is going to be interested minnesota's
going to be interested
all of these teams even that have decent
quarterback situations
may say hey look we're making a call on
this why wouldn't we
another point though as it relates to
the broncos potential interest
what they can offer the texans is drew
locke and
even though there's a different coach
and a different gm the two guys who run
the team as a practical matter are still
there
from december of 2019 when drew lock and
the broncos came to town
and kicked the crap out of a playoff
team
texans and locke was incredible that day
and out dueled desean watson so
of all the the transactions you could do
where you bring a guy to town
as watson goes if we get drew lock in
this there may be some appeal to it
because they've seen drew lock at his
absolute
best there's potential there if they
would end up with him
next topic which doesn't belong and why
free agent quarterbacks under the age of
30.
jameis winston mitchell trubisky jacoby
brissette which doesn't belong in why
wow that's a gem um
i would say jacoby brissette
um the only reason i would say brissett
because i don't think
that it's hopeless for him to ever be a
good starting quarterback
i think the other two right now uh are
valued more highly and viewed more
highly
by the rest of the league um especially
those
thinking that i will take a chance
the second time around on mitchell
trubisky
with no pressure on them just bringing
them in
and seeing what we got like for instance
and again i have no idea what's gonna
happen at trubisky
but if the san francisco 49ers next year
were to start uh jimmy garoppolo which
probably is going to happen not
certainly but probably
if they start jimmy garoppolo don't you
think that one of the things that john
lynch
uh and uh uh and kyle shanahan
have to say to each other is okay look
we love you know our two backup
quarterbacks we love mullin and beathard
but can we do better
in my opinion if i were them i'd want to
take a shot
on getting and plus you know we we
forget
too that we don't know exactly how their
quarterback room
is going to look you know because
obviously
they look like a team that's going to be
able to consider alternatives
hey when you have a quarterback a
starting quarterback a franchise
quarterback that
when he got his latest contract was the
highest paid player in league history
and he's missed 23 games over the last
three years you better have
a good backup and it better be better
than nick mullins
who had some moments last year that that
i'm surprised he wasn't
cut then and there by kyle shanahan so
i'll say jameis winston just because i
think he's got
the biggest upside by far of the three
it's just a matter of being in the right
spot
and having him in a system where they
can find a way
to to just iron out that that just that
recklessness that puts him in position
because i still think that he he tries
to do more than he's capable of doing he
needs to know when to stop he needs to
always stay within his abilities
he gets into trouble when he goes beyond
his natural abilities and his natural
abilities are great
don't try to do too much and you don't
have 30 interceptions or at least half
of those interceptions
don't happen because you were trying to
do too much when it happened
free agent quarterbacks over 30. cam
newton andy dalton
and ryan fitzpatrick which doesn't
belong and why
i would say cam newton because you know
what ryan fitzpatrick is
you know what andy dalton is you know
that both of those guys are guys you'd
really like to have on your team
uh as either backups or sometimes
starters
i just don't know what i i think cam
newton might be
really good again before he retires from
football
but mike i just don't know what he is i
do not know what cam newton is
after watching him for wide swaths of
the 2020 season
there were times where his throwing
mechanics looked off
where his arm didn't look the same
where he was inconsistent and again look
a lot of that is due to the fact that
the new england patriots
have a horrible cadre of skill position
players collectively
and that is bill belichick's fault but
i just those other two guys i know
exactly what they are
cam newton i don't know what he is
well and i'm gonna say fitzpatrick
doesn't belong and why because
he is the one guy who
when you expect nothing from him he
plays like a hall of famer
when you begin to believe oh maybe this
guy's still got a chance to make it to
the hall of fame
he's one of the worst quarterbacks you
can ever see the fitz magic who fits
tragic toggle switch
and it's like clockwork as soon as
you're all in
as soon as you're like yes it's probably
here it goes the other way if it's
tragic
doesn't it and then he gets benched and
then he comes back at some point
and it's magic again so i can't figure
that guy out it's fun
from a fan's perspective it's got to be
horribly frustrating
from the fan of a team who is relying on
hims
perspective all right free agent pass
rushers who were franchise tagged
last year matthew judon yannick
way but dupree which doesn't belong and
why
i would say the one who doesn't belong
is
matthew judon because he's the only one
of those three
that i enter this offseason fully
believing in
and and again i think that both of those
other two guys bud dupree was playing
some of his best football ever before he
got hurt this year in pittsburgh
uh yannick and gawkway had a pretty
quiet
that was a big trade at the time
remember the the ravens getting in gawk
way from minnesota
and so i i thought in gaque was going to
have
an impact run with the ravens and he
really didn't
he was okay but he wasn't he wasn't a
great player for them
so i would say the one i trust is jude
the one who's different is jude on
because
i think in almost any defense right now
he can give you a 12 sack season
uh in 2021 i'll go with dupree for the
obvious and unfortunate reason during
his franchise tag year he suffered a
torn acl that is going to
dramatically alter his earning potential
this year he's probably going to have to
sign
a one-year deal somewhere and hope that
he can play well enough to earn a
longer-term deal if he gets a long-term
deal
it's basically going to be a one-year
deal that would be ripped up by his new
team if they decide that he
he isn't all the way back it's just a
shame that he had that acl tear before
he got his financial reward he was
having a great great season he had a
great season in the year before that
prompting the steelers
to use that franchise tag nfc east
players
who were franchise tagged last year
which doesn't belong and why
dak prescott brandon sherf leonard
williams which doesn't belong and why
i would say brandon sherf because i
think the other two
are are big stars and i think brandon
sherf is a good player
um and don't get me wrong i'd want
brandon sheriff on my team
but in my opinion those other two guys
are
top five players in the in dak
prescott's case
top one player on his team leonard
williams at his peak is
you know was one of the best players uh
at a
very important position in the nfl so
i'd toss out sherf
yeah i'm gonna say dak just because he
is
he's he's unique in his
leverage in his position this is
kirk cousins five levels higher this is
a guy who is playing the franchise tag
game
and winning 37.6 million
he will get in 2021 if he's tagged and
we were talking about this yesterday
peter i think it's incumbent on
the cowboys to get to him and work out a
long-term deal a four-year contract
before the deadline for applying the
franchise tag
because they can't carry 37.6 million
into 2021 under dak prescott's name
they've got to negotiate something
with a cap number in the range of 20
million this year
if that much in lieu of 37.6
and spread out the the the rest of the
charge coming from a huge signing bonus
in future years
or they're going to have a hard time
operating
you know mike you know how you always
advocate
for taking x percentage of the salary
cap
you know telling a player look you play
at 16
of the cap whatever in my opinion
this is the year i would do it with dak
prescott only i would do it
i would do it very very slightly
different
i would say and this would have to be
worked out obviously because it can't
exactly happen this way
but let's just say as your your figure
was 16
right so let's just say that the figure
is salary cap
you know what i would say to dac okay
we're going to sign you to five year
deal
and we will give you 16 of the salary
cap
every year however in year one
we want to buy back four percentage
points
and we want to go to twelve percent of
the cap in year one
then in years 2 through 5
will give you 17 of the cap
so in other words it'll all be equal and
you will end up making more money
because of this
because the cap is going to increase
a lot more with the new television deals
and the way that would help the cowboys
is imagine
if dak is only uh you know only 12
of the salary cap this year just imagine
then his cap number is around 20.
okay so all i'm saying is that you're
right it's incumbent on the cowboys to
get this deal done
and to get it done imaginatively so that
dak prescott would say
you know what that's fair to me and it's
fair to the team
at 180 this year it would be a 21.6
million dollar salary for dak
a lot less 16 million exactly less than
what he would
be due to making but you're right you
make it up on the back end the question
though is how much of that is fully
guaranteed
and can you fully guarantee cap
percentages i know you can
make compensation contingent on cap
percentage but
if i'm back i'd worry about taking the
21.6
and uh you know am i guaranteed for
twenty of course you'd have to have
future guarantees
right you'd almost have to guarantee all
four years and uh i don't know that the
jerry jones would want to put that much
money in escrow which is one of the
realities
as to why teams don't have more than two
years of fully guaranteed money
all right the good thought though good
thought that's kind of creativity
they're going to need to get this done
otherwise the cowboys are going to be
screwed going into 2021.
free agent receivers over the age of 30
aj green
t-y hilton marvin jones which doesn't
belong and why
i just don't want aj green anymore i
just
i mean i'm i'm not drawing any
conclusions on
on anything other than what i have seen
on the field
over the last three years and i have not
seen enough to trust
that aj green is going to be any factor
whatsoever
in 2021 he might be he's the kind of guy
if i were the patriots
i would go and buy and and buy with a
lot of
backside to the contract or at least try
to
what has he done mike in the last three
years or four years
that would lead you to believe that he's
still a franchise receiver
nothing and so i look at a guy like t.y
hilton
that he's going to give you whatever he
he's like he's the jarvis landry
of the indianapolis colts and and also
marvin jones
i think he's one of these guys that when
healthy
he is still can be five times a year
potentially
a game wrecker or a big game influencer
so those two guys i would want aj green
i would not
it's amazing his catch rate last year
was 45 percent targeted 104 times
had 47 receptions for 523 yards in 16
games he didn't play at all in 2019
right we had that weird ankle injury
when they
they practiced in dayton as part of the
nfl's 100th
season and he never played it all that
year
uh he he has one thousand yard
since 2015. he started his career
with five straight he almost had a
thousand in 2016.
he had 1078 in 2017 fell off after that
and you think about it he
and julio jones came into the nfl the
same year
jones is still going strong i agree with
you on aj greene
he's still a guy who deserves a spot on
an nfl roster
he's still a guy who can help you but
he's not the guy that he was and the
question for him is going to be
will he take whatever he can get to keep
playing
or say i'm not interested in three
million or
you know especially this year with the
cap crunch
what what is an aj green gonna get
offered far far less
than what he would have gotten a few
years ago peter it really is stunning to
see how he's fallen maybe it's injury
maybe
maybe it's something else but he's just
really fallen off dramatically
free agent receivers under the age of
30. juju smith schuster
corey davis will fuller which doesn't
belong and why
oh that is a really good one i guess you
know the guy
who who i would say probably is will
fuller
um undeniable talent really good guy to
have on your team
just missed a lot of time and now coming
off a suspension at the end of this year
i'd probably give it to fuller
now davis did not start strong in the
league
but his last couple of years he's played
well and he's been productive
and juju i think he's a guy who
any team in the league would want to
have him
on their team he's a he's got a great
attitude
he uh you know he plays hard he's a team
guy
um i i re i think juju smith schuster
justifiably wherever it's going to be
vegas
i i i truly don't know where it's going
to be wherever it's going to be he's
going to make money and be a good
contributor
to a winning team please let it be the
browns please let it be the browns
please but please let it be the browns
i agree with you on will fuller look the
guy's got a serious injury history and
then he gets healthy in 2020
and then he gets popped for using peds
what a shock
now he's got to go back to not using
peds he's not going to be healthy again
i would not trust that will fuller is
going to be able to be on the field for
me on a regular basis because
he's got that one and i look they've all
got an excuse
i got i used a supplement that i had no
idea contained whatever the banned
substance was
under that standard they never catch
anyone who cheats i don't believe
any of them because they all say the
same
thing i'm not look i understand the
reasons for doing it i'm not judging
but if they're going to have a rule in
place that says you're going to get
suspended
just just admit it when you do it don't
don't give us this this cockamamie
i got a spiked supplement thing although
will fuller may have i don't know
i i heard he's going to sue somebody
they always say they're going to sue
somebody over it let's see if he does
last topic free agent running backs
kenyon drake james connor
aaron jones which doesn't belong and why
uh james connor as much as i love james
connor
he's a very easy guy to love uh
he's one of the great team players in
the nfl
i have no idea how many games going to
suit up for me this year
he's just been hurt a lot and i know his
story his story is an inspirational
story
you know coming back from cancer it's
but
you know as far as getting a guy to be
your
horse in the backfield if you sign james
connor you
almost have to you you have to have a
coach
and a coaching staff that is going to
say
we are a two-headed monster okay that
is what you have to do if you are going
to do that
you have to be like the indianapolis
colts you know where you got three backs
marlon mack you know was hurt this year
uh
you know jonathan taylor and nahim heinz
you know they
are not going to ever get left
behind at the running back position
becomes situation
and if you sign james connor you have to
have another back in your stable
who you are comfortable with and you're
fine with
if he's got to carry the load when
conor's out
i'm going aaron jones for one very
simple reason he's the only one of the
three
whose hall of fame starting quarterback
has come out and called him an mvp
candidate now that happened in 2019
jones was kind of up and down didn't
have a lot of great performances in 2020
but had enough
but i think a real litmus test type of a
player from the standpoint
of are the packers committed to helping
aaron rodgers will they put
the people around him will they keep
aaron rodgers or will they go back to
the draft well
and and hope to bring in a young guy
that is wet behind the ears that aaron
rodgers is going to be dealing with for
the next few years so
i think it's a real test what the
packers do with him as to whether or not
the packers are willing to make
aaron rodgers happy peter it's gonna be
hard to do
it's tough to justify a big investment
at the running back position because
there are so many guys every year
who are coming out of college who can
get it done for so much less
than what you would pay to a running
back but you know roger's got to be
looking at what happened last year derek
henry got paid he did well
alvin kamara got paid he did well dalvin
cook got paid he did well
why can't we pay aaron jones and assume
he'll do well
the problem with that with that logic is
mike at least
in my opinion is that the road is
littered
with guys who you pay very well as
running backs
and you go down the road a little bit
you know the le'veon bell road let's
just say
you go down the road a little bit and
you say to yourself
what were we thinking and
and again you can't see it at the time
you don't see it at the time
but there's a reason and i and i'm gonna
be off with this a little bit but
don't take running backs and then after
they play
great for three or four years then you
pay them a mint there's a reason
because you know alvin kamara 67th pick
in the draft
uh you know kareem hunt same year and i
forget his number but it's around
78 or something like that alvin kamara
great
kareem hunt wins wins a rushing title as
a rookie
so the logical thing to say is well we
khmer was early in the third round and
kareem hunt was middle of the third
round
let's just take more running let's take
cam akers
52nd the rams did that
you know and he was great this year
until he got hurt
and so all i'm saying is that you can
find running backs don't get lulled into
this thing where we have to pay a
running back
and i think there are some people who
are different and
surely there's no question about it
you know that derek henry is different
but for the most part mike i would not
give running backs
gigan i'd give them second contracts i
would not give them gigantic second
contracts
and when you think back over the past 20
years or so on alexander where they got
backed into a corner to pay him big
money after he was the league mvp in
2005.
that was about the same time you started
to see teams use two
and three running backs so you avoid a
situation
where you have all eggs in that one
basket
the fans fall in love with him he's
scoring touchdowns he's a great fantasy
football player everybody knows who he
is
you you have this larger than life
tailback on your team
you're just gonna let him walk away and
and piss off sorry london and manchester
and liverpool your fan base
no you gotta keep him it becomes
political and you avoid it
if you have the the revolving door at
running back so
look the packers can clip the last five
minutes
and show it to aaron rodgers as long as
they take out the parts where i talked
and maybe they can
maybe they can get through to him and to
agree to see it their way let's take
i just hey i just know this mike if
if i'm the green bay packers i'm just
not paying the running back i'm paying
other people
sorry hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports